na keine Zeit für Fasching hä na Ihnen
kann geholfen werden freuen Sie sich auf
unsere neu entwickelte aktions-box
Fasching to go mit unserer Jenny aus dem
geschulten Serviceteam erleben Sie eine
typische Faschingsveranstaltung in nur
30 Sekunden die Essenz von Fasching
sozusagen und das tolle daran sie haben
so noch mehr Zeit für ihren stressigen
und dämlichen Job aha bereit ja na dann
los Jenny Stufe 1 Verkleidung
Stufe 2 Stimmung
Stufe 3 tanzen
Stufe 4 Küsschen
Stufe 5 Eskalation unser neu
entwickelter Fasching to go Cocktail aus
hochprozentigem Alkohol und lustigen
Amphetaminen das tolle hierbei man wird
nicht nur sofort betrunken es wird einem
auch sofort unfassbar übel wie am
Fasching genial oder und wenn sie
Fasching to go jetzt bestellen gibt's
gratis noch ein unehrliches Kind dazu
typisch Fasching herrlich oder es ist
die schönste Fasching meines Lebens die
Essenz von Fasching in nur 30 Sekunden
mit Fasching to go
[Applaus]
[Musik]